billion dollars into the project his
money and his name
gave the deal credibility and then the
nfl the raiders las vegas and the state
legislature
jumped on board to make it happen about
halfway through adelson left the project
bank of america stepped in to complete
the deal but by that time his work was
done and a major stadium for las vegas
was going to be built
and today nothing could make it could
have made him happier
he was a fan of las vegas and he was a
fan of growing our industry
and the one thing that mr adelson
understood was that a rising tide
lifts all boats and so he knew that that
stadium would be good for all of us
because our convention center fills
other people's rooms
we cooperate very effectively with all
of our our competitors and colleagues on
the strip and bringing
shows to las vegas
and yes las vegas will forever be
changed on the south end of the strip
with allegiant stadium there adelson now
he wasn't really a fan of the raiders
didn't have to be but
as you heard andy abood say there he was
a fan of las vegas indeed in building
the city and the the brilliance of that
vision that he had was on full display
as you drive
past the legion stadium the raiders
owner mark davis offered his condolences
today
saying that the best we owe uh sheldon
adelson
will never be forgotten in what he's
been able to do here for the city in the
newsroom
i'm ron futuro reporting 8 news now